In Belgium, US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo...
...traveled to European Union headquarters in Brussels,...
...the first stop on a European trip to discuss tensions with Iran.
In China, the Chinese government has announced...
...it will impose higher tariffs on US exports after President Donald Trump...
...sharply boosted levies on Chinese products headed to the United States.
In Sweden, prosecutors are reopening a rape case...
...against WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange.
Swedish authorities also say it is for Britain to decide...
...whether to extradite him to Sweden or the United States...
...where he is wanted for allegedly hacking into a Pentagon computer.
Millions of voters in the Philippines cast ballots Monday in a midterm election...